congressional investigators said they
have found troubling irregularities in
the FBI's investigation of Hillary
Clinton or email server according to a
report in the hill FBI agents had their
investigation micromanage by
higher-level officials in contrast
ordinary practice you know what that
means the investigators also told the
hill they found evidence the FBI began
drafting an exoneration of Hillary
Clinton before it even gathered all the
relevant evidence or interviewed more
than a dozen key witnesses Chris wacker
is a former assistant director of the
FBI and he joins us tonight this tracker
thanks for coming on evening Tucker so
you've seen this report I don't think
anybody any American wants to believe
the FBI is not on the level or subject
to political manipulation but that's
conclusion I'm reluctantly reaching
what's your conclusion well as an
experienced investigator it doesn't take
a congressional investigation to tell me
that nothing about that investigation
was right I mean we that have conducted
federal criminal investigations know
that you use the grand jury you use
search warrants you don't hand out
immunities like candy I mean everything
in that investigation runs contrary to
the way a real credible thorough and an
FBI investigation is conducted so give
us as you're watching this give us the
specific examples that tipped you off
that this was this was not unfolding as
it ought to have been well first and
foremost in any complicated federal
investigation the basic tool of the
trade is a grand jury and use of the
grand jury to obtain records you don't
you don't go to witnesses and say mother
may I have that computer hard drive may
I have those emails you use subpoenas
and process and grand jury and search
warrants and that sort of process so
that was the tip-off from the beginning
so many deals were made with people not
knowing what kind of information they
had and the the deals being made simply
because they lawyer it up and didn't
want to talk to FBI agents that's when
you throw them in front of a grand jury
well exactly because a lot of subjects
most subjects I would think lawyer up
and nobody wants to talk to the FBI of
course but the FBI doesn't normally cave
to that does it no Majin Comey was a
deputy attorney general running the
corporate fraud task force and I was
running
the Criminal Division and we were we
played hardball
in those investigations you use grand
jury process you didn't just ask for
records and he didn't give them an
opportunity to hand over what they
wanted to hand over and if they did
lawyer up you went to the trouble of
throwing them in front of a grand jury
to put their their statement on the
record or they can take the fifth and
then you can make a decision as to
whether to grant them immunity at that
time but none of that was done in this
case this was like driving a car with
the brakes on what why wasn't it done do
you think you know that's what puzzles
myself and all of my former colleagues
people who have retired from the FBI
from from executive level positions on
down to the street level and the only
thing I can I can come up with is that
director Comey placed the investigation
in the hands of his inner circle and
they had their own agenda obviously when
we've seen that from some of the some of
the information that has since come out
the text etc so you think it was
political I think that there were people
inside that inner circle in the Comey
inner circle that had their own
predetermined opinions about the Trump I
mean excuse me about Hillary Clinton and
the president or the ways what them was
a president-elect or someone running for
president so let me ask you but
something that I found really striking
tell me if you had the same reaction so
we now have documents that came out in a
lawsuit that show internal documents
from the FBI that when the then Attorney
General Loretta Lynch had that famous
meeting on the tarmac with Bill Clinton
his wife is being investigated at the
time the FBI's first reaction was not to
figure out how did that happen
the first reaction was to find out how
news of it leaked that seemed like a
very weird reaction to me it's not the
FBI that I know and my as I said my
former colleagues that I compare notes
notes with all the time that's not how
things were handled and in former
directors Comey commis rationale shall
we say for making this prosecutor
decision that the FBI director has has
no business making that she was not that
he
that she was not to be prosecuted that
that was based on that that tarmac
meeting well that were the case all he
had to do was hand the investigation to
the attorney general's office
let her recuse herself from that making
that decision knock it down to her
number two level person and then if that
didn't happen then maybe raise the issue
publicly it's really distressing to
watch this
thank you for your perspective of that I
appreciate it my pleasure